can tax help protect the environment
hello my name is too cute I design
rocket-propelled clothes I came to earth
because I am fascinated by your shoes
there is no such thing on my planet I
have a great idea I will design
rocket-propelled shoes Europeans love
shoes I will make my shoes in the
European Union but if I owned a factory
I don't want to damage the environment I
wonder can tax help protect the
environment come with me
let's investigate
[Music]
that doesn't look good what happens to
the flowers in park when that smoke
covers them how about their children
they look affected by the smoke
[Music]
is your father all right he looks a bit
sick he is not alright he suffers from a
lung disease caused by the smoke of that
factory he's taken medication we needs a
liver place is not so badly polluted I
have seen the damage caused by pollution
to the environment and also to people
someone has to do something about this
what can be done to protect the
environment and the people from
pollution the state is already taking
measures to help repair the damage from
pollution and to stop people causing
pollution how is the state helping the
state collects environmental tags to
finance activities which help to protect
the environment also factories are asked
by the state to install filters called
catalysts that reduce the environmental
damage our people also protected from
this damage these activities help to
heal the environment so that people and
their kids can live healthy lives what
our environmental taxes environmental
taxes are paid on activities that have a
bad effect on the environment and harm
Planet Earth
good I understand now but tell me more
do these activities have a bad effect on
the environment yes they poison the air
water and earth this is why energy taxes
are paid by the companies who produce
the energy and by people who use it
[Music]
transportation affects the environment
so it is taxed too right yes you've got
the idea to reduce the negative effects
on the environment the state is banning
from circulation or imposing higher
taxes for older cars with larger engines
that have more emissions than the new
ones this is massive pollution do they
just have to pay taxes no if they are
responsible for an accident like this
they will pay a bit fine as well the oil
will kill the birds animals and fish in
the sea also water is polluted by the
thrown plastic garbage plastic only
deteriorates in 300 years so it affects
the wildlife a lot for example in some
EU countries plastic bags are taxed to
reduce their use
this business makes money from cutting
down the forest do you think they have
to pay tax yes because the lumberjack is
altering the natural environment and is
using a precious resource exactly one of
the measures taken by the state in this
case is to oblige landowners to clean
their terrains and plant new trees
congratulations to cute you just learned
about environment taxes does anyone in
your family pay an environmental tax can
you give some examples how do you think
that environmental tanks helps to
protect people
[Music]